اليوم لم يعد يرضينا الدور ربع النهائي لم
يعد يرضي جماهير المغربيه حتى نصف النهائي
ربما يعني صار امر يعني ااا عادي جدا لانه
الهدف الان صار تحقيق اللقب الهدف الان
صار الوصول الى النهائي وتحقيق اللقب
المغرب من شيخ خطوه من الدور الاول حتى
هذا الدور
نعم امن بحظوظه نعم نعم حلم بتحقيق لقب
ولكنه اخذ المباريات واحده واحده عدى
كرواتيا عدا بلجيكا وبعد ذلك تجاوز
اسبانيا وتجاوز اليوم البرتغال وسيلعب
امام الفائز من انجلترا وفرنسا وسيفكر
بتجاوزه هي خطوه خطوه ماشيه الامور وماشيه
بشكل صحيح وبشكل مدروس وبشكل دقيق اليوم
لما تنزل تلعب امام منتخب البرتغال لاعب
مش خايف عم تلعب معهم هجمه هجمه كره كره
البرتغال بس انت فعليا اللي عامله بالملعب
انه خطورتك على مرماهم اكثر من خطورتهم
على مرماك هجماتك عليهم اكثر من هجمات
قادر تتحكم بمتى ممكن تهاجم متى ممكن
تدافع بشكل خطوره بكل الاشكال والطرق ممكن
على المرمى البرتغالي
رقم بعض الفرس البسي اللي كان ب شوط
المباراه الاول بشوط مباراه الثاني رغم
الاجهاد البدني اللي بين واضحه اللاعبين
رغم الاصابات اللي صارت واصابه عمود
الفريق الاساسي رومانسايس قائد الفريق
وقائد المنتخب
وركيزته الاساسيه رغم ذلك لم يتاثر
المنتخب مين منصور المنتخب
البدني قل بعد بدايه الشوط الثاني بدقائق
قليله همم وليد الركراك على طول تصرف
حسينا انه المباراه بلاش تهرب من المغرب
بلاش تروح باتجاه المنتخب البرتغالي اتصرف
راسا وغير طريقه اللعب الى شكل اقرب
للخمسه ثلاثه اثنين او خمسه اربعه واحد
وسكر كل المساحات الممكنه على جونزالو
راموس وعلى كريستيانو رونالدو وعلى جوافه
وشفنا منتخب مغربي ماسك وقادر يحمي منطقه
بالشكل اللازم طبعا بمساعده ياسين بونو
اكيد ولكن هل تتخيل انه المنتخب المغرب
عم يلعب بدون قلبين الدفاع الاساسيين نايف
اكراد مصاب ورومانسيه نصاب لهيك اضطر ان
يلعب بداري ويلعب بايامق ويلعب ببدر بانون
اليوم بالشوط الثاني او بمعظم دقائق الشوط
الثاني
نصاب زياش تبدل زياش نزل اللاعب اخر محله
معظم اللعيبه اللي نزل منسوب البدني كان
دائما في لها بدائل هذا بدل على انه هذا
فريق عنده عمق مثل ما حكينا المباراه
بلجيكا فريق المغرب قوته بانه يمتلك عمق
تشكيل قوي جدا وكبير جدا قادر يوديه بعيد
بهذه البطوله هاي البطولات تحتاج الى عمق
وتحتاج الى مدرب شجاع يتصرف بالوقت
المناسب مثل ما اتصرف وليد الركراكي في
هذه المباراه
نعم هو امر لا يصدق بالنسبه لجماهير
المغربي ولكن بالنسبه للاعبين انا متاكد
ان الموضوع عادي لانه في فرق كويتي
بالنسبه لمنتخب المغرب كان اليوم على
منتخب البرتغال في فرق جوده حكيمي مثلا
اجبر مدرب البرتغال على اخراج جريرو نحنا
عم نحكي عن فرخ جوده عم نحكي عن فريق جوده
اضطر مدرب البرتغال فرناندو سانتوس انه
ينزل بكنسلو ليش نزل بيكنسلو لحتى يحاول
القدر الامكاني يخفف من تقدمات حكيمي
الهجوميه ولحتي يفرض عليه ضغطي خليه يجيب
ويضل وراء ولكن
كل الظروف وكل الاشكال وكل التغيرات
الممكنه رغم المنتخب البرتغال كان يهاجم
بخمس او ست لاعبين في نهايه المباراه رقم
ذلك منتخب المغرب كان صامد ان يخطف هدف او
هدفين عندي رساله يعني الجديره وليد جديره
رجاءا يجب التعامل بشكل افضل امام المرمى
اليوم الفرص اللي ضيعها وليد اشترى كان
ممكن ضيع التاهل على المغرب فرص سهله فرص
بسيطه لا تحتاج الى كل ذلك لذلك رجاء وليد
جديره يجب ان يكون اكثر حذرا بهذا الامر
اكثر هدوءا امام المرمى واكثر حسنا للتصرف
لحتى يخلي المغرب تعدي الى الادوار
القادمه ويكون فعلا بديل ممتاز تنصيري
لقطه نصيري وتسجيل الهدف كانت غير طبيعيه
لارتقاء غير طبيعي تسجيل غير طبيعي اللي
شفته كان رائع جدا اشرف حكيم اليوم هو نجم
منتخب المغرب بلا شك سفيان مرابط كالعاده
رائع كان كل لاعب المغرب كانوا ابطال
وسفيان بوفال كان بطل ايضا جميع المغرب
تحيه للمغرب على هذا الحلم المستمر والان
لم نعد نتفاجا لم نعد نصرخ حتى نهايه
المباراه المباراه
الطموح الان صار تحقيق اللقب تحقيق اللقب
يا مغرب وانتم قادرون على ذلك مبروك
للجمهور المغربي ومبروك لكل لاعبي والجهاز
الفني بقياده وليد الاكراكي ولاكيد رئيس
الجامعه فوز الاقجعه وللجميع لجميع العرب
وللجميع المنتخبات الافريقيه التي اليوم
ساندت المنتخب المغربي
[موسيقى]